hello there you may be expecting a map
update video from me but this island is
too big and too new so instead I've
tried to find things you probably
haven't seen yet as well as highlighting
the most important areas that link back
to storyline and maybe the future and
then I'll throw in a few Easter eggs and
some theories too please think about
using Code adamaru if my voice doesn't
annoy you let's do this
probably the greatest new thing about
this island is the random chance of a
map change in your game constantly at
any moment an exclamation mark will
appear on screen which leads to a micro
Rift opening up and bringing over an NPC
and something from our past the very
first one I saw was this the original
Hench Bros chilling by a campfire I
don't know about you but I was unsure if
they'd make it to the new island and
then during the event we saw them
standing on a rock waving the Bromance
lives on so the next question was where
are the rest of the Misfits and sure
enough there is a chance they will all
riff into existence together in my game
they all arrived in the snow biome with
makeshift beds keeping warm by a
barbecue and occasionally one member
would go ice skating pretty epic I'm
hoping they will stay permanently and
maybe start their own POI somewhere it's
possible for madcap to appear with 20
plus mushrooms around him for you to
consume and there are reports his
dancing fun guy friend
spawn too my favorite is the farmer and
his chicks this dude absolutely loves
those chickens so much he even plays
their music and should you decide to off
some of those chickens he is so broken
up he'll cry and I kind of feel sorry
for him let's do another one before we
move on it's possible for this to happen
Loveless a master criminal can be
portaled onto the island complete with
her recent plunder from her latest bank
robbery six safes full of gold and if
you want you can take it all but just be
warned stealing from a thief won't go
unnoticed there are tons more mini
events to find please do me a favor
write a comment below if you found one
of these I want to try and compile a
full list of random events that can
happen this season cheers
oh during the event was one of my
favorite nods to save the world there's
a part where a few characters are
running around the cuddle team Leader's
head this totally took me back to the
old animation back before Battle Royale
even existed good days speaking of that
cuddle team lead ahead it is indeed on
the new island the old roller coaster
nut can be found here and that's not the
only reference to the older Seasons the
IELTS Fortress drill from chapter 3
season 2 is here still covered in paint
from the celebrations of defeating the
imagined order and if you think we've
defeated the imagined order oh no my
friend take a look under the battle bus
this season and there is their logo
There Is No Escape the io will be back
soon over in the snow I'm sure you've
noticed this one the OG Clock Tower once
again is in disrepair this thing has now
been reconstructed so many times I've
lost count and it remains one of the
oldest items still with us tilted Towers
was first constructed back in January
2018 and this is its last remnants
another small Easter egg can be found up
here the old gas station slash petrol
station sign laying on the ground this
actually links to another Easter egg
last chapter the gravestone when this
was created it was in homage to players
who used the old spill like sign to yank
themselves across the map for easy
rotations it didn't always go to plan
hence the gravestone and I wonder who
will be the first person on this new map
to be immortalized in a gravestone and
that leads me to the Herald's tree the
bringer of the nothing is permanently
entwined with the old reality tree which
looks to be gone forever Unless somehow
it grows back I'll be honest with this I
was a little let down by the battle with
the herald I kind of expected more and
it so happened there was more intended
in the event a leaked work in progress
video shows the real intended ending of
that event everything is as you've seen
it until the herald merges with the tree
then a wide shot of the last reality's
mothership is seen racing towards the
zero point which then lifts that orb
into the ship but the zero point has
other ideas and straight up destroys
that vessel this would have tied into
the story a little better but I guess
epic have other ideas about what they
want from the last reality the only link
to them we have in the game right now is
bikes who became their Warrior last
season so I guess we just wait and see
now
[Music]
a place I demand you visit and look
around
ipala in Slappy the ink squid is its
spiritual animal and inside it's like a
history lesson of fortnite there's a
llama statue from the old Coliseum a
skull from the old desert biome and
skateboard decks from over the years but
it's the sheer volume of tattoo art
around this place from Midas to meowzels
to peely to fish sticks and look an
entire mural wall dedicated to the Chaos
Agent octo Inc is amazing somewhere in
here is a clue to the future but I can't
find it oh and while in Slappy you'll
notice slap juice is the big star on the
island that's the consumable drink
everyone wants but look hard enough and
you'll see that the slope Juice company
is still here but it's desperately going
out of business I'm so down for a
storyline to bring that brand back come
on Epic save slurp juice an unnamed POI
that must be important to the chapter
can be found here a circular floor which
would perfectly fit a zero point inside
it covered firmly the glyphs on the
ground look to be planetary alignment so
let's steel charts and there is a ritual
site close by as it's day one of the
chapter if you have any chapter 4
theories please throw them in the
comments let's see who thinks like the
mustard we call Donald and can predict
the future
something I wanted to look into was the
new Midas boss or rather the Ageless
firstly does this mean we are in the
past or the future because I really
don't know but more importantly I felt
like I'd seen that style of armor before
and those statues too so I wrecked my
brain and remembered a game epic made
that cannot be played anymore Infinity
Blade it was an early mobile phone game
rather basic but it had cool law and it
was quite addicting in that story it was
medieval based yet some people had
technology from the future and some
could not be killed they were called the
deathless these Knights constantly seek
the Infinity Blade yep the very same
thing we wielded back in chapter one and
also in that story the creator of the
sword was locked away in a vault very
much like this one here here's the thing
that really sells it to me as a
crossover to the world of Infinity Blade
remember the rooms found on Kevin the
cube and the last reality they were
first seen in the Infinity Blade Games
so if this was a prequel it would
actually link into both of their laws
this could be recycled ideas and reused
assets but how cool would it be to link
both those games together
[Music]
on the island when in this location
you'll hear the song of the Crustaceans
and should you look on top of the crane
nearby here they are the wobbly blobs
have survived another chapter keep your
ears open they're actually in more
places than you expect especially on
shorelines even in the snow it's been
almost two years since they lasted
anything worth noting yet I still waste
my time finding them rocket League's
octane car did not make it to chapter
four but a new rocket League poster can
be found in The Farmhouse someone who
lives here really loves rocket League a
poster for each season a very strange
sight can be found in multiple locations
are these frog statues one of them is
actually made out of ice I'm clueless
what this represents but I do have a
far-fetched theory geralt of Rivia is
coming to the game and once in a DLC
called Heart of Stone he fought the Frog
Prince I told you it was a stretch frogs
and finally during the live event it was
revealed that crackshot's cabin was
indeed saved and it it already had a
Christmas tree ready for that update in
a few weeks but I can't find it on the
map is it yet to arrive or am I not
looking hard enough I'm Adam thanks for
your time I'll be in my Twitter DMS to
thank people who used my code this week
it really helps stay awesome I'll see
you next time
[Music]